christian mccaffrey taking to social
media on monday thanks for all the kind
messages the work continues and he knows
how to put that work in and he has
gotten rewarded for the work yes he does
performed in three nfl seasons 16
million per year on a four-year
extension he's not even 24 yet chris and
he uh already
you'd call him that we just call him the
best running back in football right now
there'll be some other guys that could
make an argument that they're as good if
not better but a thousand yards rushing
a thousand yards receiving only the
third guy in nfl history to do it
joining marshall falcon roger craig i'd
say that puts him up there
yeah i mean he's the best all-around
running back in the sport right now i i
got no problem saying that do i believe
maybe he's the best pure runner in the
sport you know no i think that's
debatable i would say there's two or
three other guys in that conversation
but regardless
who well i i i mean i'm gonna i'm gonna
look at nick chubb i'm gonna look at
dalvin cook in that conversation i think
those guys got special attributes you
know i mean ezekiel elliott if he can
improve on what he did last year too he
could be special that way derek henry
you know i think during the conversation
for that best pure runner type guy
but none of them
care are as good as mccaffrey is in the
past game i mean mccaffrey learned how
to run routes from his father you know
his father is an all-time great round
runner so now you're a freak of nature
with muscles popping out all over your
body and your dad's taught you the
nuances of running routes you know he
runs routes as good as any receiver on
the carolina panthers and that's really
what separates him let alone he's got
great physical ability
a couple of guys who are clearly on deck
for long-term contracts or not derek
henry of the titans under the franchise
tag this year he has signed the tender
he and the titans have until july 15 to
work out a long-term deal and kenyon
drake traded from the dolphins to the
cardinals last year did enough to get
the cardinals to say see you later david
johnson put the transition tag on kenyon
drake at 8.48 million this year he has
that july 15 deadline as well and chris
here's the challenge for the teams do we
make the major financial investment and
run the risk of what we've seen happen
when so many other running backs get
that huge pot of money or do we say keep
chasing the carrot you'll get rewarded
eventually by us or maybe by someone
else
well i think that's where the teams are
going to have to really take into
account the player that they have on
their roster and his injury history and
where he's at that way you know i think
carolina was very comfortable with
christian mccaffrey because they've seen
the way he works and they know the state
of his body which is his business that's
that's what it is he hasn't been injured
a lot and mike we talk about this a lot
he's not a car crash runner you know the
one thing we've seen with christian
mccaffrey all these carries at stanford
and now into the nfl you know he's such
got such great quickness and elusiveness
he very rarely gets squared up and
crushed and that's what i think teams
are going to have to take into account
is what type of football has that
running back played what's the state of
his physical condition and do we feel
comfortable paying him and if you feel
comfortable paying him and you feel all
those things are in the positive
direction like wow i think we could do
it to me the smart move is to get out in
front of it and pay the guy you know
after the third year
and just get it done and throw him out
of offer that's big time but maybe a
little bit below market value or
whatever it may be
but i think you're going to get a lot of
running books to bite the hook on that
one because they know how dangerous the
position is and that they only got a
certain amount of years as far as shelf
life is considered playing running back
in football
i mean for mccaffrey the biggest injury
risk uh would fall into the tom brady
chris sims la lakers purple and yellow
down there
uh category
when he tries to hurdle when he tries to
hurdle someone who's wearing a helmet
which i think they've convinced him to
not do that all you have to do is take a
helmet to a sensitive area once and uh
you probably learned not to do that
chris it started as baltimore ravens and
then it worked its way to los angeles
lakers colors okay just so you know it
was very purple and black and then it
got to yellow and purple okay that
that's that's when you know it was a
deep bruise when it turns yellow uh
that's your uh medical
training couple of other guys a couple
of other guys who currently are on deck
currently are eligible for new deals and
want them you mentioned dalvin cook
we've talked in the past about alvin
kamara and look camara is the guy that
the saints would say is every bit as
good as christian mccaffrey they just
don't give camara the touches that the
panthers give mccaffrey the saints were
one of the pioneers at the rotating
running back remember when they got
reggie bush and we all thought he was
going to be gayle sayers we thought he
was going to be the guy who was at usc
and he ends up being part of a three-man
weave at running back that's what the
saints do they use at least two guys so
camaro hasn't had a chance to generate
the big numbers but you know per per
touch he averages 5.82 yards mccaffrey
averages 5.87 so per touch they're
pretty much the same level of performer
well that i mean they do i mean kamara
is special too there's no doubt about it
and mike like we talked about with
mccaffrey you know the importance to him
and that football team in carolina
because of joe brady running the sean
payton offense you know as you and i
both know a guy like alvin kamara is
he's everything it's michael thomas get
him the ball and then it's a a category
of plays on sean payton's playlist that
is get alvin kamara the ball not only to
run the ball but to catch the ball out
of the backfield so yes i don't think
he's as talented as a runner as
christian mccaffrey is uh and nor do i
think he's quite as good of a route
runner but alvin kamara certainly in the
conversation for one of the best running
backs in football but you know to your
point mike how much can he command when
he doesn't have maybe the numbers that
are eye-popping like a christian
mccaffrey or some of the other running
backs in football
yeah look i i it's it's uh
here's the question you have to ask
yourself
if you're an alvin kamara
do you take
i do you understand that you're not
going to get that huge contract but
the way they're using you you're going
to earn and you're going to play
a lot longer you're not gonna flame out
and you know there was a time when i
would ask running backs would you rather
be the guy that has the ball 25 to 30
times a game or do you understand the
value of being part of a rotation and it
was almost 100 i want the ball i want
the ball i want the ball now i think
guys are starting to realize there's
value in longevity there's value in you
know hitting ground rule doubles over
the course of 10 years versus hitting a
home run for two or three and so right i
think i you know i don't think
the saints aren't going to give camara
16 million a year they probably won't
know 15 million a year but but the the
thing is he's gonna he's gonna continue
to be a key member of that team and and
this is the the argument that sean
payton and or mickey loomis need to make
to his agents
he's going to make a hell of a lot more
money over the next 10 to 15 years 15
may be a stretch but over the next 10
than he would if if we did burn him up
the way the panthers are burning up
christian mccaffrey yeah i i mean i
think that's a real conversation that's
something alvin kamara is gonna have to
weigh himself and then also know where
his body is at in that conversation you
know he was a guy that was banged up
last year he told us that he didn't feel
100 towards the towards the until the
end of the season but you know i look at
kamara you know the other one you
brought up with dalvin cook that would
be the guy that i would be most
concerned about if i was advising them
because dalvin cook is a car crash
runner he runs through that hole like a
bat out of hell and he takes people on
and yes he can outrun them and make them
miss but he's certainly not shy of
contact and he's not a big guy either
that would be a guy if i'm dabbling cook
i'm starting to go
minnesota i don't know how good you guys
would have been last year if it weren't
for me and i might be starting to to ask
for money you know that would be one
that jumps out mike and how about this
guy too we forgot about how great
okay go ahead i want to say one thing
about dalvin cook and then we've got to
take a break okay he's missed nine he's
missed 19 games in three seasons yeah
last year was his first healthy year in
the nfl and they love alexander madison
i mean there's no guarantee the vikings
are going to pay down
they may just turn it over to madison
and just keep keep that meat grinder
going and find a guy every few years
like the broncos did when we talked
about the zone blocking the one cut find
somebody else find somebody else find
somebody else and and never give anyone
that big contract the vikings learned
the hard way what happens when you give
a running back a big contract he kind of
takes over your offense and you become
one-dimensional like they were with
adrian peterson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports